how's cumbrous my name is Zack coal that
coal with the kids today we're going to
explore the darkest places you may have
every once in a while seen weird link
like lemonparty why did someone link
that well i better click on it oh my god
what the [ __ ] well that's basically what
we're gonna do today so I recommend
locking your door putting on headphones
taking off your pants don't please don't
do that I'm gonna okay I probably have
to censor a lot of this but I'll link
each website in the description so you
can click along alright let's begin with
the classics this one apparently has 54
percent shock factor its meatspin calm
I've seen meat spin
[Music]
why okay hi to you I have not seen that
either set it I've seen worse not any
problem let my party [ __ ] I don't
remember what lemon party is oh yeah
well old gay people needs love too
that's all I'm gonna say about that one
I have not seen this one jar squatter if
you think you've seen everything well
just watch this Galia for [ __ ] sake is
he gonna cut off his dick no now what is
he gonna do what is happening
always putting up a jar
Oh
[Music]
all that genuinely made me upset blue
waffle I remember but I don't remember
what it is and I'm genuinely terrified
don't don't go to blue waffle don't
don't click on blue waffle special fried
rice all right well this it's kind of
being a failed video I'm not gonna do
any more of this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] this
[ __ ] everyone I'm gonna go and cry